they're often called man's best friend
but an increasing number of studies that
are showing dogs may be an effective way
to find covid-19 faster than current
tests from detecting the disease in air
travelers to those in healthcare various
groups have found the canine's ability
to be extremely accurate the dogs have
the ability of correctly identifying
cases of covid with a sensitivity and a
specificity above 90 Dr Martha Charles
works with the canines for CARE program
at Vancouver Coastal Health which
trained three dogs on finding cover 19.
in Vancouver's case it's done by having
the dog smell masks or unscented tubes
formed by positive and negative patients
or the saliva of these groups other
studies had dogs give a person a quick
smell then sit down to indicate a covet
case the dogs in Vancouver are then
rewarded when they correctly identified
the disease so they associate a positive
case to a rewarding scent Dr Carla Simon
with Hunter's heart scent detection
canine says reward is a common method of
dog training we just have to make it
rewarding for the dog Recent research
out of the University of California
Santa Barbara gathered multiple
peer-reviewed studies and asserted the
dogs could be more efficient faster and
less expensive some studies saw the dogs
go through thousands of samples in a few
weeks Tommy Dickey says the power of a
dog's nose may be able to prevent the
spread of kova 19 by detecting pre and
asymptomatic cases the longer the weight
is between your chest
and your result that that's a latent
period during that time you're running
around spreading covet and you don't
know it the dogs with a direct sniff
will be done in seconds well Dickie
study suggests dogs could be less
expensive Charles cautions the amount of
people to train and then screen are
where the costs could come in but she
adds the dogs can still be a tool to
prevent more transmission and possibly
even to detect other viruses and
diseases so I think there's a bright
future for medical scent detection dogs
a future that has many hoping dogs will
be the next breakthrough in finding
pathogens Sean prevel Global News